et voilà c'est l'été à 50 ans nous avons
retrouvé wilfried ritchie pour l'été en
sable à montigny avec eric stalner
bonjour bienvenue pour le 7 8 et et nous
sommes à montigny le bretonneux on
aurait presque l'impression d'être en
vacances en bord de mer avec tout ce
sable à proximité on va parler de l'été
en sable l'initiative de cette
installation éphémère revient à la ville
de montigny le bretonneux c'est la
sixième édition on va en parler avec
jean-pierre d'auvergne élus à la vie des
quartiers
bonjour jean pierre domergue bon je vais
lui en charge de la vie des quartiers
sur montigny le bretonneux alors expédié
nous c'est la sixième édition de l'été
en sable à montigny pourquoi avoir voulu
marcher sur les traces de paris plages
comme ça et faire de la concurrence à
paris plage ce que nous pensons pas que
celle inverse
saison qui avait initié un mouvement non
c'est pas nous les initiés sur mon team
et effectivement l'idée qu'on avait ce
n'est pas tellement de concurrence et
paris plage c'était surtout de
de procurer aux imans teint
des activités d'été pour ceux qui ne
partent pas l'idée il y avait une
vocation sociale derrière alors il ya
une vocation sociale ou est tout à fait
ceci étant c'est ouvert à tous
gratuitement et enfin sauf sauf
certaines animations et dans l'ensemble
c'est gratuit et c'est à la fois pour
ceux qui passent l'été à montilliers
mais à la fois également pour ceux qui
ne passent qui passe une partie l'été
par exemple ceux qui partent ou en
juillet vienne en août et réciproquement
et comme les gens prennent j'ai de moins
en moins de vacances compte tenu en
particulier des conditions économiques
eh bien ça leur donne la possibilité
pour les adultes comme pour les enfants
jeux de prolonger des témoins de moins
en moins de monde pour pouvoir partir en
vacances aujourd'hui c'est très
compliqué de moins en moins de monde qui
voit là il peut partir vous avez un
petit peu des statistiques des données
sur montigny le bretonneux on sait qu'au
niveau national c'est un français sur
deux cette année qui a annoncé ne pas
partir par exemple au ce doit être à peu
près là j'ai pas de chiffres précis en
tête mais ça doit être à peu près ça no
ken vraie attente autour de ce rendez
vous annuel chaque année ça monte en
puissance chaque année ça monte en
puissance et chaque année on nous
demande de prolonger donc on a commencé
avec un mois et puis on a augmenté
progressivement jusque là avoir deux
mois c'est à dire vraiment toutes les
vacances scolaires à partir de la date
de sortie des classes jusqu'à la rentrée
le début de saison était difficile avec
les conditions météo est là on n'a pas
eu forcément sur la fréquentation sa du
61,7 au fait on avait commandé le soleil
mais noté livré avec un peu de retard
j'espère que là il va rester
suffisamment mais c'est vrai qu'on a eu
débuts difficiles avec des journées
pluvieuses et journée on était obligé de
fermer aussi l'été ensemble parce que
quand il ya que de la pluie on peut rien
faire on peut pas faire tourner
d'activité on peut aller sur le sable
parce qu'il est mouillé
combien d'associations sont mobilisés
est ce que tous les services de la ville
aussi participent à ce rendez vous qui
êtes un moment là il ya plusieurs
organisations de l'année où est tout à
fait il ya plusieurs services en fait
ceux qui participent c'est ceux qui sont
en relation directe avec la population
donc il ya le vide quartier bien sûr
qu'ils aient tirait le service
probablement le plus proche de la
population il ya également les sports il
ya également les atsem donc pour les
centres de loisirs voilà tout le monde
tous ceux qui sont proches de la
population participe donc il ya
différentes tranches dans la journée et
dans la semaine
le matin ce matin je crois que c'était
les atsem qui étaient là voilà et
combien de personnes au total vous
attendez sur ces deux mois d'ouverture
je crois qu'on attend environ 15000
personnes
actuellement on en est d'après les
chiffres que j'ai eues on doit en être
quelque chose comme cinq mille personnes
déjà quand même et
avec une fréquentation journalière par
beau temps comme ça et monsieur seigneur
vous dira plus que moi mais et ses
environs sont 105 600 personnes merci
jean pierre d'auvergne et rick steiner
on va aller le rejoindre tout de suite
il va nous parler des animations qui
sont proposées ici justement
toujours à montigny le bretonneux pour
cet été on sable 2012 avec eryl steiner
bonjour je vous charger de
l'organisation vous chapeauté cet
événement alors quels sont les moments
forts de cette édition alors les moments
forts en fait on a voulu sur cet espace
sur les deux mois qui tue d'ouverture
composé des animations à destination de
l'ensemble du public qui fréquente
l'espace c'est à dire à la fois les
familles plutôt des petits un peu moins
les ados et puis les jeunes adultes on
va dire donc pour les familles on trouve
des activités qui sont un peu tendance
en ce moment du type e zumba tai chi et
c'est vrai c'est quoi justement alors la
zumba c'est une espèce d'aérobic on va
dire mais sur des thèmes un peu
hâlé afro-caribéens etc même si parfois
ils étaient quelques débordements sur le
style musical donc ça marche plutôt bien
on a fait la première la semaine
dernière il y avait trente sept
personnes s'est tous les mardis soirs
c'est une animation en accès libre et
gratuit ce qui permet aux gens de
découvrir des activités potentiellement
les poursuivre sur le reste de l'année
au sein des structures municipales comme
à la piscine 30 aquatique au club le
village donc on essaye aussi en fait
d'associer le tissu associatif ou des
choses qui sont proposés dans des
structures de la ville pour que les gens
puissent profiter de ce moment pour
découvrir des activités assez variés
donc je disais zumba tai-chi donc ça
c'est des choses plutôt sympa pour les
petits un certain nombre alors on essaie
d'avoir des semaines à thème là par
exemple on va voir à la fin du mois
d'août une soirée country par exemple
donc tout le long de la semaine on va
faire des choses qui sont plutôt en
relation un peu far west pour les petits
donc ça va être du déguisement du
maquillage la fabrication de costumes
des ateliers marionnettes avec un
l'écriture et spectacle à la fin avec
les enfants et une production donc mais
toujours un temps fort chaque semaine
qu'on peut retrouver sur le programme et
puis ensuite il ya les petits activités
qui s'inscrivent sur la durée qui sont
des choses qui marchent bien perdre
estivale
scooby doo bracelets brésiliens
voilà des grands classiques qui ont fait
venir faire des pâtés de sable c'est
quand même il y aura des bâtisses à bien
servir nos activités effectivement c'est
effectivement là pour ça donc on essaye
d'en profiter au maximum façon que vous
voyez aujourd'hui il est bien occupée
ont créé des petits espace motricité
pour les tout petits c'est des choses
que les parents et les enfants adorent
donc ça on est parti pour deux heures et
ça va pas désemplir la structure
gonflable en arrière pour mais pas tout
le temps parce que sinon c'est pas très
drôle mais voilà ça fait aussi partie
des choses qui attire on essaye en fait
d'avoir sur une journée un découpage on
va dire en heurts avec des activités qui
permettent de cibler l'intégralité des
publics qui fréquentent l'espace et
celles improvisées aussi on peut revenir
d'une journée sur l'autre et on aura
toujours quelque chose de différent il y
aura quelque chose de différent et puis
ya malgré tout ses fils conducteurs
comme je disais tout à l'heure si on
fait par exemple en fin de semaine une
animation autour des pirates eva toute
la semaine on va fabriquer les
déguisements les accessoires et puis on
va réaliser les chasses aux trésors et
c'est donc à cette espèce de fil rouge
mais si les enfants sont pas tous les
jours c'est pas très grave ils peuvent
se raccrocher au wagon assez facilement
s'il ya un moment à ne pas manquer si on
peut venir qu'une seule journée ce
serait laquelle alors alors s'il ya un
mois ne pas manquer ça s'arrête pour
quitter parce qu'on est un programme
vraiment attractif g et rory est assez
riche d'animations qui est vous vous
séduit le plus peut-être vous viendriez
si vous n'étiez pas en charge de
l'organisation juste pour le plaisir
alors si c'était moi par exemple je
viendrais volontiers pour les échasses
urbaines
tout à l'heure on disait c'est vrai
qu'il ya pas grand chose essentielle
pour les ados malgré tout on a voulu des
moments pour eux mais qui sont aussi des
moments pour les parents on aura une fan
journée dédiée au foot freestyle par
exemple avec initiations démonstrations
etc et une journée dédiée aux échasses
urbaines ce quelque chose d'un peu
ludique qui peut se pratiquer sur le
terrain multisports derrière où il ya
aucun risque de se faire mal voilà ça
c'est des choses que j'aime bien on a
deux soirées thématiques une 27 juillet
qui sera une soirée avec repas spectacle
initiation danse sur le thème afro
caribéens et une autre le 22 août si ma
mémoire est bonne autour du country
voilà ça c'est des soirées qui marche
super bien on fait 70 80 personnes si le
temps s'y prête pas mais je suis sûr
qu'il va faire beau on pourra toujours
se replier dans le gymnase 6,6 pour la
layette arriver est arrivé il faut y
croire et ses espèces de moments un peu
privilégié où on peut faire des choses
alors c'est intéressant que ces moments
comme une élite et où les rencontres se
font les enfants sont là on travaille
avec des associations locales c'est
aussi moment de les valoriser de les
faire connaître nous on est là pour
organiser et cadrer la soirée voilà
c'est des moments très sympa l'été en
sable s'est ouvert jusqu'au 2 septembre
c'est ouvert jusqu'au 2 septembre regard
du rôle angers d'une semaine cette année
parce que la rentrée scolaire est aussi
un peu plus tardive c'est ouvert tous
les jours de 10h30 jusqu'à 20 heures
sans intéresser gratuit et c'est gratuit
en ex quelle que soit la commune où l'on
réside pas forcément montigné on peut
venir au delà tout à fait de saint
quentin on m'invite au département des
yvelines merci à rick steiner 11 ans
pris l'été en sable jusqu'au 2 septembre
pour la suite de ce cette suite été nous
partons du côté de plaisir à la spa
christelle et à rencontrer des bénévoles
forcément très actif durant cette
période donnée
cours
à
comme vous le savez sans doute c'est en
période estivale que tous les animaux
sont abandonnés et la spa de plaisir à
pauline a bien besoin de bénévoles pour
les aider à garder tous ces petites
bêtes là avec des trognes mignonne alors
je vous invite à découvrir la spa et
puis faire des vacances utiles en menant
aider l'équipe sont abolis
bonjour marie laure merci à vous
accueillir dans votre nouveau centre
tout beau tout neuf on s'est installé
dans le nouveau refuge depuis le 18 juin
donc c'est tout récent et donc combien
d'animaux pour accueillir nous avons
l'actuellement nous avons une centaine
de chiens et
150 ch aps le centre
on a eu une personne supplémentaire mais
voilà on a le double de travail donc
c'est assez dur on a des journées bien
chargées et comme on est en été on a
beaucoup pensionnaires dont classe et
c'est un peu dur mais on le sait l'été
c'est toujours très très dur
clément
je m'appelle martin chez bénévole depuis
septembre à plaisir et je viens la
semaine puisqu'on n'y a pas trop de
bénévoles la semaine beaucoup plus le
week end avait donc c'est vrai que les
filles ont besoin la semaine voilà donc
comme je suis dispo donc vous faites
quoi en tant que bénévole et bien
les ménages
la nourriture laisse pas trop les soins
puisque je suis pas à 100
ban
et quelles conditions pour pour être
bénévole dans son dos aide alors on fait
remplir un dossier de névo là pour pour
être aussi assuré parce qu'on travaille
qu'avec des animaux dont il ya toujours
un risque de morsure ou de houe enfin
voilà donc il faut quand même être
assurée et puis il faut quand même être
assez grand si par exemple des jeunes de
14 ans d'être accompagnés d'un adulte on
ne peut pas comme ça nous les gars d'ea
sous notre responsabilité on est déjà
très déborder donc on a avancé mais en
temps de s'occuper de
ses terres
du monde
et
tous
dans ce
vous vous attachez à tous les animaux
pas moi je serais pour sa survie le juge
mondial a commis sa peine je sais même
pas parce qu'il a même pas de nom il
fait que des bêtises il attend juste à
quelqu'un pour venir la dot est vite
trouvé un an voilà
et donc vous êtes à la recherche cet été
et tout au long de l'année de bénévoles
oui tout à fait on les bénévoles sont
d'une aide très précieuse on en a déjà
on en a beaucoup mais les bénévoles
viennent quand ils peuvent quand il voit
quand ils auraient consulté devenir on
en a en semaine on en a le week end ils
sont les bienvenus parce qu'ils nous
aident à faire notre travail et du coup
nous si on a du temps consacré pour les
adoptants ça nous permet de mieux faire
notre travail d'accord et en quoi
consiste donc qui peuvent vous apporter
un bénévole vient à l'origine camaro
pour faire lui fait plaisir on lui
impose pas on a des bénévoles qui
viennent juste promener les chiens c'est
pas juste ils viennent en premier les
chiens auraient juste à côté voilà et
parce que enfin voilà n'avait pas
spécialement faire autre chose on a des
bénévoles qui viennent nous aider pour
le nettoyage donc au niveau des chiens
donc ça ça nous agace aussi beaucoup on
a des gens qui viennent nous aider pour
les chats le nettoyage en a d'autres qui
passent du temps juste pour les
sociabiliser voilà il caresse les
bénévoles font aussi le skipper et ils
sont là aussi pour se faire plaisir
je veux pour mon art eux elle est par
terre
je veux tout
est donc maintenant nous partons à la
ferme de gally où rôdent va apprendre à
wilfrid à faire du pain